hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
I'ma keep it real with you guys
this stream sucked again a little bit of
a ramble today there really wasn't much
to talk about I will explain that right
now as during the stream they showed a
bunch of the stuff we already know for
the event they showed the new menu
screen the new mask outfits and the new
weapons and I'm not gonna waste your
time by showing that stuff on screen I'm
not going to show the entire thing on
screen because already posted a couple
videos of that explaining so the first
one was showing all the cosmetics we
have the new masks outfits the new event
the new effects I'm sorry and we have
the weapons and all that stuff that
comes with it basically everything that
comes with in the event and if you need
to buy it with steel or if you need to
loot it with in-game and then the stuff
that is lootable I did make a video the
day afterwards explaining how to get all
that stuff the fastest and I will leave
all those they'll both those videos are
gonna be the end of the video today so
don't worry I highly recommend you guys
check those out if you haven't I know a
lot of you have and you guys are very
appreciative that and I love that
responding to those comments saying guys
so much for all the support on those two
videos and another really random comment
they also mentioned that they're gonna
start going it with a different types of
metal for the weapons so as so
definitely expect some newer weapons in
the future obviously this was super
obvious to anybody that's played this
game for more than two minutes but just
in case you were wondering so want to
let you guys know that when weapons
coming in the future might have some
different types of metal structure so I
believe one of the recent ones they were
using Damascus steel so they might do
some other types of metal which is
really cool to look for I mean they do a
really good job on these weapons so I
can't hate them for that I'm gonna carry
to see what they're gonna be doing next
season also on video as you're seeing
right now is going to be the idol emo
and execution effects for the mask the
reason I didn't cover this in my past
video is because I don't have 80,000
steel to blow on four mask outfits that
I'm never going to play with so there's
that clip for your viewing pleasure if
you wanted to see that or if that was a
breaking point if you wanted to use the
mask or not with the effect so there's
that already but I really want to talk
about what's been happening in this past
week with for honor and how it's just
been super disappointing Monday was
going to be the huge III conference for
for honored Tuesday and Wednesday was
going to be the show matches and
Thursday was going to be what was today
this other warriors than at e3 which is
all exciting throughout the entire week
until it actually happened
on Monday we were all hyped just dance
came up before us got a lot of praise
I'm thinking if just dance is getting a
lot of hype we gotta get hype too turns
out we really didn't get that much hype
for our trailer because none of the
developers came out to talk about it no
one came out to explain what the event
was all they did was showed the trailer
Ubisoft logo came up trailer came on for
two minutes and Ubisoft logo came on
again and then we went on to the next
game which I believe was Rainbow six
quarantine which honestly looks [ __ ]
amazing random comment but love Rainbow
Six definitely gonna get the quarantine
game but yeah that was it two minutes
that was our trailer everyone was pissed
I've never seen a more bigger like to
dislike ratio on a video for foreigner
than the event trailer right when I was
watching it on Monday it was at 500
likes the 300 dislikes as soon as it
uploaded I don't know what it's at now
but it's probably pretty bad cuz while
the event was really good and I will
admit the event is really solid the
event the event game-mode is sick the
soul rush game-mode the weapons are cool
the effects are nice they just showed it
off really poorly and it's really being
taken at face value so I just want to
preface that I'm not saying that the
event is garbage the event is awesome
the way they showed it off in a way that
they even had to explain that at e3 was
terrible
I talked to multiple people in my
discord and on my Twitter and everywhere
a my youtube comment section about what
people thought they wanted to see it III
we had multiple different comments of a
new faction Season eleven year for a
sequel all of that was completely untrue
I had a feeling that they were gonna
show off the new event because we
haven't had any info on this event
previously but I thought they were gonna
show off the event maybe talk about it
and then give us a teaser for what's to
come next and not even that happened no
teaser no-one even came out to show it
and that was probably the most
disappointing part ever all the
youtubers I talked to basically took it
as a punch to the face we absolutely got
[ __ ] by this even the community as
well not just us as youtubers everyone
got basically screwed over this trailer
they hyped us up saying that they were
going to e3 and we remembered our past
with the marching fire trailer and how
absolutely insane that was and how they
showed it off how cool it was Roman came
up talking all like he usually does -
everybody up for the new trailer and the
new faction and this is what they ended
up
coming up for the sequel of e3 move on
to Tuesday and Wednesday nothing was
really shown there it was just more of
the soul rush game-mode which we've
already seen just a few community
members playing it while that was still
really cool got a lot of community
members involved and I'm assuming that
they had a lot of fun playing these
matches and from a viewer perspective
who's already probably played multiple
matches of this and really just wants
fresh content that wasn't really their
thing and then on Thursday was supposed
to be the Warriors then which is the day
that I'm recording this it started at
about 3 o'clock my time when they
usually start at 12 so about three hours
before they actually started today and
they said it was going to be a two-hour
show I was very excited even if they
took a majority of the two-hour show
explaining of what we want what we
already knew as long as they showed a
picture of the new character or knew
something I would have been fine I could
have made the video completely about
that but that wasn't the case they
started this stream they talked about
the new event showed off the new weapons
all the stuff that we already knew and
of course I've already covered so like I
said I'm not going to show it again
they've got we've already covered all
this stuff before they showed off
everything and then at the very end they
go okay we're gonna go into some soul
matches and I'm like that's perfect
we're gonna shelf the soul rush
game-mode again people that haven't seen
it can watch it I've already watched it
myself so I wasn't really too interested
I've played it and experienced it myself
so that just wasn't me and then right
after that they said boom thank us for
watching tune in next week to the next
more years then we're gonna be talking
more about the new hito Kira event come
next week and that was the biggest slap
in the face that I've ever received I
started I've got donkey punched in the
[ __ ] neck from that I had a feeling
that they weren't gonna show [ __ ] but
they they didn't even tease us for
what's going to happen next week and
they most likely won't show anything
next week besides of what's gonna happen
in the new event I'm assuming we're
gonna get in a new type of emote for the
first week or the second week of the
event and that's cool I always like new
emotes I like that they get to come up
with all the stuff and most of the time
it's pretty good for this event
currently the emote that we have is
actually really nice I do like the
possessing stuff and it's really cool
but that's not really what everyone's
interested in anyone with a small IQ
even can understand that majority of the
community wants to know about the hammer
hero we want to know what's happening
for year four and hell some people even
want to know if there's a sequel
involved most of the people though
really want season 11 stuff
and even though we're halfway through
the season and still have about a month
to a month and a half left before the
season is over we still have some time
and I feel like that they could show
that also it is June 13th I think as I'm
recording this right and we still have
yet to get a road map that was the other
thing that a lot of people in the
comments mentioned usually when they do
these road maps it's at the very
beginning of the month and that we get
to lay out the entire month of what's
happening and as of right now we don't
got [ __ ] even on a road map yet if they
showed a road map then we can know when
to be hyped for certain things but they
don't even show that yet maybe they'll
show it next week I hope they do because
they're leaving us out of the loop right
now and this is a terrible way of them
doing the Warriors than in this e3 I'm
gonna finally shut the [ __ ] up I'm
losing my voice
I'm absolutely disappointed this week
Monday was supposed to be the biggest
type ever for foreigner whenever your
favorite game goes to e3 it's always
especially from a YouTube standpoint it
just means a lot of people are coming in
to the new game even if it's a present
game that's already happening like a
rainbow 6 or for honor that means new
people are gonna come to the game
possibly check out your channel and they
can grow but the way that foreigner
keeps doing this stuff it's not helping
either of us it doesn't help the
youtubers make good content instead we
have to make rant videos like this and
everyone that's done an e3 type of
discussion has basically said the event
is cool III was garbage but it also
doesn't help out the community because
while they don't have to focus making
videos all the time as a community
member and just a person that plays the
game you want to have that new fresh
content you want to have that good you
want to have fun with the game and when
they do stuff like this it basically
just ruins all the fun for you but yeah
like I said I'm gonna shut up finally I
just wanted to speak my thoughts
I usually don't speak my thoughts on
this stuff and a whole entire dedicated
video but seeing as there was literally
nothing today I needed to speak out
about this it's kind of [ __ ] and I'm
finally I'm just so over this still
gonna be posting videos in this game of
course we're gonna cover next week's
video which got to see what that is oh
yeah let me know what you guys think
about III in the comments below about
400 let me know what you guys think
about Season eleven anything you want to
talk about in the comments definitely
let me know I'll try to have a
discussion with you love talk with all
of you in the comments also shout out to
all the people in the YouTube stream
they finally enabled chat for the
warriors dense stuff shot out to
everyone that came in said all the
hellos and stuff that made my day thank
you guys
we had like to be if you do enjoy
subscriber for new
this score to be in the description down
below and my two most recent videos
which are the guides I talked about in
the beginning will be at the end of the
screen and invited a couple seconds but
that guys take care enjoy the rest of
your day and enjoy the event and peace
out
[Music]
[Music]